SO in this lesson, we are going to be looking at how to improve the IPC
without a folder execution and how to design actual hardware that does that. For
improving the IPC we have seen that the ILP can be good, it can be significantly
larger than one. Usually it is way over four, but to achieve
something close to that ILP, we need to handle the control dependencies. And
we have seen how branch prediction can help eliminate control dependencies if
branch prediction is correct. So if our branch prediction is very good, which,
on today's process it is, then as far as control dependencies are concerned,
our IPC will be very close to the ILP. Then we have to consider the write after
write, and write after read data dependencies, also known as false dependencies,
and we have seen that at technique called register renaming can completely
eliminate these dependencies so that you simply don't have them anymore in
your program at which point they're not going to be a problem for out IPC. And
then the, we have seen that there are these write after read also known as true
data dependencies. And we have seen that it helps a lot when you can execute
instructions out of order, meaning you don't simply follow the program order,
you simply find instructions whose inputs are ready and
you execute them then. That is how ILP mostly was good. And finally,
there are these structural dependencies, which is when you cannot execute things
simply because you don't have enough resources in the processor. But that can be
solved simply by investing in a, into a wider issue processor, meaning we
need a processor that can handle. A bunch of instructions in each cycle and
not have to delay instructions just because it doesn't have resources for
it. So among these, we really need to figure out how to do these three. And
first, we will focus on this. So, how do we actually do register renaming and
out of order execution in a way that can be amenable to hardware implementation?
So we know how to do it kind of manually on paper, but how does a processor
actually do it? So this lesson will really focus on how to do this for real